a record-breaking crowd came out to
honor the late DJ Tim Bergling Nonna as
Avicii in his hometown of Stockholm
Sweden Bergland Bergling was just 28
years old when he died by suicide last
year after his death his parents started
the Tim Bergling foundation to advocate
for the recognition of suicide as a
global health emergency they put on
yesterday's - our tribute to raise
awareness for mental health it was
streamed around the world and included
performances by some of each's biggest
collaborators an all-star tribute to one
of the world's most beloved electronic
artists with singers like Adam Lambert
Rita Ora
and Aloe Blacc coming together for the
first time to perform avicii's biggest
hits
[Music]
[Applause]
nineteen singers performed alongside a
full 30 piece Orchestra which avicii's
father glass Bergling said was one of
his son's dreams we spoke with him in
October about the Tim Bergling
Foundation which he and his wife unki
created in memory of their son what's
your goal with the foundation trying to
get the stigma away from talking about
mental illness and suicide we hope we
can be a voice through Tim because Tim
had so many millions of hands I've been
anxious in a documentary film before his
death Avicii talked openly about his
anxiety depression and addictions I
can't see a way for me to do this and be
happy about it he quit touring in 2016
to focus on making music but less than
two years later Tim took his own life
what would you say to fans of his who
might be dealing with with some of the
things that he dealt this you have to
talk about it and you have to you
shouldn't be afraid to ask for help
the money raised from the concert will
go to organizations that provide mental
health resources honoring Tim's life one
of those shining stars impacted the
world with
and his legacy the 55,000 tickets sold
out in 30 minutes
everyone who performed perform for free
I know I know how much it meant to his
father what a beautiful tribute to
Avicii and it also draws attention to a
very important really important cousin
that's very important to the family very
nice